the batman might just be the darkest big
screen adventure for the caped crusader
yet but what will younger viewers make
of it keep watching for things only
adults notice in the batman
at the onset of the batman we see an
armed robbery and an attempted subway
mugging on a rainy gotham evening in a
voice over the caped crusader waxes
philosophical about his war on the
criminal element saying they think i'm
hiding in the shadows but i am the
shadows for some batman's brooding tone
and delivery may call to mind
rorschach's inner monologue from the
opening of watchmen the 1986 series by
alan moore and artist dave gibbons often
credited with paving the way for
grimdark superhero stories which was
adapted into a 2009 film by director
zack snyder moore and gibbons or frank
miller for that matter didn't invent
hard-boiled detectives who engage in
foreboding interior conversations that
trope dates back to the late 1920s
however the parallels between rorschach
or the archetype he represents and this
batman don't end with the beginnings of
their stories like batman rorschach is a
masked vigilante who keeps a journal
loaded with phrases like this city is
afraid of me i've seen its true face but
unlike most cinematic iterations of
batman rorschach has zero qualms about
murdering criminals and his sense of
morality leaves no room for gray areas
there's some rorschach in batman but
there's also some rorschach in the
riddler as well and in their use of
voice over they may all owe something to
double indemnity it began to rain
outside and i watched it get dark and
didn't even turn on the light
that didn't help me either
according to widely accepted notions
about the motion picture association's
rating system a pg-13 movie may contain
exactly one use of the infamous f word
any more f-bombs than that kick the film
up to an r rating preventing
unaccompanied miners from buying tickets
and potentially damaging the box office
takeaway especially for a major
superhero blockbuster like the batman
generally superhero movies don't bother
cursing at all or dive headfirst into
full-blown r-rated territory but the
batman walks the line since the film has
a single precious to give you might
expect to hear it during an intense
emotional moment that's not what happens
early in the movie batman and the gotham
city police department investigate the
scene surrounding the riddler's murder
of mayor don mitchell jr observing that
it happens to be on october 31st
commissioner pete savage turns to the
dark knight and mockingly wishes him a
happy halloween it's as if the batman
picks up its one and only f-bomb and
casually tosses it aside just to get it
out of the way
this film knows it doesn't really need
to swear but that doesn't mean it will
let a perfectly good f-bomb go to waste
considering dc has been publishing new
batman stories on a constant basis since
the late 1930s it's pretty wild how
filmmakers keep returning to frank
miller and david matsukelli's batman
year 1 from 1987 for inspiration there
are certainly many other batman comics
that could easily be movies but
hollywood really loves year one
apparently the bare bones premise of
year 1 in which batman gets the hang of
being batman and befriends detective
james gordon provides the partial
foundation for 2005's batman begins
however the batman also borrows from
miller and metzkele while managing to
avoid retreading director christopher
nolan's earlier reboot fiercely
protective of her friends and more
interested in targeting corrupt elites
than thievery for its own sake zoe
kravitz selena has more in common with
the catwoman of year one than any prior
on-screen take of the character maybe
we're not so different
who are you under there meanwhile the
gotham city of the batman excluding an
abrasive downtown that's a clear
stand-in for times square resembles
matt's kelly's worn down over-developed
gotham that recalls the new york city of
the 70s and the 80s
he writes terrible goth poetry he's mean
to his surrogate parent he has inherited
responsibilities he wants nothing to do
with does that sound like the greatest
superhero of all time or a self-involved
privileged teenager if bruce wayne was
real don't you think he'd come off as an
angry arrogant jerk dismissed as an emo
brat by the times critic who doesn't
like this movie pattinson's bruce wayne
is one of the more explicitly flawed
takes on the world's greatest detective
we've seen committed to screen he's
dismissive toward the ever loyal alfred
pennyworth and alienate selena before
the end of their first reconnaissance
mission batman wants everyone to fear
him but cops and penguin flunkies alike
all laugh right in his face at one point
batman bungles a major clue at another a
daring rooftop escape ends in a
humiliating crash landing oh you're
really not as smart as i thought you
were batman related media has a habit of
telling us batman is a normal guy with
no superpowers while showing us a
character who via top tier deductive
capacities and an unlimited supply of
gadgetry might as well be considered as
omnipotent as his kryptonian bff
meanwhile the batman offers us a dark
knight who actually is a normal guy with
a ton of personality defects who is also
bad at things he tries to do sometimes
he's still got a lot of money but
there's nothing god-like about this bat
sometimes in superhero movie discourse
folks will use the terms dark and
realistic interchangeably this is wrong
and the batman demonstrates why compared
to frank gorshin's definitive
performance in the 1966 batman tv series
and jim carrey's bonkers take in 1995's
batman forever the riddler from the
batman is far
far darker aside from the traditional
practice of dispensing riddles to batman
and the gcpd to make his crime sprees
more interesting he has little in common
with his predecessors this riddler is
much more murderous than the riddlers of
yore to the great misfortune of several
gotham city public servants paul dano's
riddler demonstrates tendencies lightly
meant as homages to other films his
executions of commissioner savage and
district attorney gil coulson instantly
call to mind saw and its affiliated
series of torture romps while batman and
the gcpd raid riddler's apartment his
piles of journals promptly harken to
john doe's apartment in seven riddler
even turns himself over to the
authorities just like dome in david
fincher's 1995 crime horror masterpiece
this riddler is darker but he is not
more realistic we know this because john
doe and jigsaw from saw are also
imaginary characters they are just as
unlikely to exist in the real world as a
bank robber who taunts authorities with
gimmicky silly clues and dresses up in a
green tuxedo covered in question marks
it's probably not realistic to expect
the main character in a major studio
blockbuster to express what socially
liberal folks would consider an
enlightened attitude about sex work
still batman doesn't think twice about
grilling selena a woman he barely knows
about the possibility that she might
have done some escort gigs while
employed at the iceberg lounge at one
point selena reluctantly reveals that
carmine falcone is her father not her
customer because it's the only way to
get batman off a freaking back about it
but let's consider the counterfactual
scenario what if carmine was selena's
client what if selena had a whole bunch
of former johns does batman bring her to
jail at that point is it any of batman's
business at all there's definitely a
chauvinistic and judgmental component to
bruce's initial attitude towards selena
which is to be expected this is a more
immature batman than we're used to he's
been sheltered and insulated by insane
amounts of wealth his whole life still
you'd think a guy who runs around in a
form-fitting animal-themed outfit
wouldn't be this minded
at this moment in superhero movie
history we just saw three versions of
spider-man from different eras joined
forces in 2021 spider-man no way home we
might be on the cusp of professor
charles xavier joining the mcu after
decades as the licensed property of a
different movie studio and michael
keaton is returning to fold his
decades-old batman movies into the dc eu
in 2022's the flash as seemingly all the
other superhero franchises lean into the
science fiction aspects of their source
materials to cultivate fanservice and
corporate synergy this version of gotham
city feels way too grounded for any of
that wacky nonsense
not only are there no references to
other dc superheroes the batman doesn't
even have quasi-fantastic elements like
the high-speed military tank batmobile
or the league of shadows from the
christopher nolan trilogy the previous
standard center for gritty realism in
batman movies in fact matt reeves told
esquire i respect that the dc universe
has become an extended universe and all
the movies were kind of connected but
another batman film it shouldn't have to
carry the weight of connecting the
characters from all those other movies i
didn't want them in there who the heck
knows what dc has planned but if ninjas
are too magic adjacent for this batman
don't expect to see him hanging out with
kryptonians amazon princesses
intergalactic peacekeepers or folks who
can run through time
to some extent since 2008's iron man and
to a much greater extent since 2012 is
the avengers basically every superhero
movie is either on the trajectory toward
a big team up about a big team up or
dealing with the aftermath of a big team
up almost all of these films take place
in a shared universe that includes a
bunch of other films many superheroes
talk as if they're being written by
someone hired to mimic joss whedon's
style circa the early 2010s even the
ones who don't and that includes
denizens of the adult and serious comic
book movies tell tons of jokes you're
gonna do that thing where you open up a
weird ass case of torture devices while
inexplicably detailing your master plan
and how i don't fit into it the batman
however is not funny the only other
movie it indirectly advertises is it's
yet owned to be officially greenlit
sequel the batman only introduces one
surprise character from the comics who
isn't in the trailers there's not even
much in the way of obvious potential for
toy licensing in this movie despite its
arguably messy execution of too much
story the batman feels like an emphatic
step away from the mcu paradigm assuming
it's the first movie in a series
hopefully it carries on in that
direction the mcu is good and fine but
we already have one of those we also
already have a dc cinematic universe
that very much wishes it was the mcu
maybe the batman will be the start of a
third thing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]